髪の毛黒にしよう
あ昨日ハイライトを増やしてきました
こんにちははじめそうです水に届きました
本当にねほんと最近届いた私がチャンネル
登録者数1000万にこういったのはいつ
だと冷笑がたして12月の23日去年の
10年823日だった気がするんですけど
も両ヶ月ぐらいカーっていう気がするのは
多分もう
なるでしょう
あげていきますほど物に関してはさあ
四角いさんも既に開封されているから何か
改めて僕がこうなんか大々的に動画にする
子どもをないのかなと思ったんですけども
やっぱりいつも動画を見てくれている
みんなのおかげでチャンネル登録
1000万に行けたのでさすがに10日に
させていただきますいやーそうぜひ届く
までさあ届くまで何か実感があったたと
いいますか
雑になった2つあっつになったわ
ああああ在来ラって
いや逆だおっちゃんだもうこんな大があっ
たのだがめっちゃズッシリしてるんです
けどこんな重いんだね銀の再生ボタンも金
が再生ボタンも見たことあるからわかるん
だけどちょっと重みが違う分後イイーッ
やりますね何か読ませていただきましょう
夏海著
も youtube をご利用いただき
ありがとうございますあなたがチャンネル
登録者数10万人を達成したときは融合の
新しいチャネルとして評価されました君丸
に立っ雪時は特別な才能とクリエイターと
して評価されましたせついに1000万人
という実に驚くべき数字を達成されました
そうよねー
ゆっくり降りる人多いんだって1000万
ってあなたのチャンネルはもはや単なる
素晴らしい2ちゃんねるではなく社会芸
照度を言えるものですと世界中のフィルと
思う日本だけですよ日本でジェラーも別に
その動かしたと思ってませんけどもや本当
に猫の1000万人っていうのはもうマジ
で俺だけじゃないからみんなのおかげだと
思っていますささやかながら
youtube から感謝のしるしとして
敬意を込めてダイヤモンドクーデーター
アワー問屋門の先生ボタンですね想定させ
ていただきますこれからの活躍に期待して
います元もよろしくお願い致します
スーザンさんう youtube の
ceo の子ですねえ
4ヶ月待ちました
いや何かう皆さんの photo 7遅い
と言いたいわけじゃないんですけども
クレーム的な理由ではないです本当にただ
なぁ
もうあれから4ヶ月やありがとうござい
ます本当に海外から届くから時間もかかる
んだろうねほんと口酸っぱく言うけどさ
みなさんのおかげで1000万人突破でき
ました本当にありがとうございますうわぁ
すっごぃアタッシュケースみたいなって
いうかねあげます
[音楽]
本の英語が継げないんで売れるだろここで
ラー t もなんかなん
yeah
はカッコイイなぁ何か改めて見たらすごい
なぁこちらがダイヤモンドの再生ボタン
ですクッカー雪が
降めっちゃ打てるんだねーめっちゃ映るん
だね後ろ恥ずかしいちょっと肇社長って
書いてありますありがとうございます休み
ませんちょっとあの親分が多分すでに動画
でされていると思うんですけどもぜひ皆
さんと共有したかったので動画ですさせて
いただきますすごいなぁ
なにすんだろうぶれてしまうのがいいので
端したケースに入れておくのが正しい気が
するやすげーめっちゃくちゃかっこいい
ありがとうございますよねあの
ダイヤモンドの再生ボタン1個だけじゃ
なくてプラス10個まで発注できるらしい
んで一応頼んであるんだよ著書待ち
くださいまずはほんとオリジナルの1個が
来たかって感じですこれちょっと東京じゃ
なくて静岡の案件のうちに方理由だと思い
ますえええ
でですよ本題はここからなんですよあの
チャンネル登録者数1000万人いた人
しかわからない悩みが実はありましてん
あるんですよあのあるんですよそれも本当
に多分30節1000万に入ってないと
わからない悩みこれじゃあ俺のガレット
ヒカキンさんくらいしかさも理解されない
気がするんですよねあのですねもうもう
単刀直入に言いますよあのですね皆さん僕
のチャンネル見てみてください今スマホと
かで見てる人パッと見てると思うんです
けどうんネル登録者数1010万人って
書いてあると思うんですよ実は1010万
人入ってからしばらくずっと1010万人
で0
はじめしゃちょー
3ネル登録者数
止まってんじゃねーみたいにわからないと
これと考えていいかも知れませんすいませ
ん少なくと俺は思っています折れそう見え
てるんじゃないかと思って1010万人
から数字が動かなくなっちゃったんですよ
なんですけどもうちょっと今確認しますね
正確な僕のチャンネル登録してこれガッツ
これガチの正確な今の僕のチャンネル登録
者数なんですけども今線
180,000
9948人後1万人ちょいで線20万円に
行くとこまできてるんですよねほぼ
1020万人なんですけどなんか
チャンネル登録数が1,000万に超える
と僕以外のみんなが見えるみんなが見れる
チャンネル登録者数のカウントがずう万人
単位になっちゃうんですよ
だから今以前2番に見えてるんですけど
本当はもう
1020万子なんですよああーっ
あのはじめ雪をチャンネル登録者数は今誰
のぶっちゃけています本当に皆ありがとう
一応チャンネル撮ろうチェス伸び続けては
いるんですけど10万人対になったから
11になんないんだ見たらある1010万
人で完全にと貼ってんじゃねーみたいな
11万人にもならないし住人にも13にも
あっ始めちゃっちゃ
時てないみたいな感じに見えられるかと
思っていてそれはそれでいいんですけど
なんかね1010万人じゃなくてそこから
8万人9万人増えてるのにそれがみんなに
見えないのがちょっとなんかあのん
寂しいなというかなんか1000万に入っ
てからこの関東になるのはもう仕様上
システム上 youtube さん的に
仕方ないことなのかもしれないですけどね
んが決してさあ89万人増える事って
そんな簡単なことじゃないからさ
1000万にこういったからといっていれ
ば1万人
事金みたいな感じなのがちょっと俺は
ガーッというかなんかせめてずう万人で
潰れるんじゃなければ1万人ずつでもいい
から入れた方が利用者さんの皆さんとか
美味しいれてる人とかもなんか一人その
数字が伸びている感じを共有できるのかな
と思ってはいるんですけどパッと見
1010までが止まってるように見えて
いるのかなぁああああとか思っちゃったり
もうしてますこれは本当1000万に入っ
てからの話なので束ほど-2サンとか俺と
か純矢くんとかしかわからないような話だ
と思いますけどずう万人カウントになっ
ちゃってるっていう18万人19万人
だろうと皆さんには1010万人に見え
てるよっていう感じなんですけども
google さんとはてくれないから
言え悩みテイカーのみんな動物ってるん
だろうというかがてちょっと俺の気にして
気がせんですけど地盤に増えたら一番に
増えたってちゃんとなんかみんなにも
見れるといいなあというか1000万人
超えたからやっぱ規模が大きいので数値の
人ずつカウントにわたってはいるんです
けどなんかい
1万人増えても嬉しいからさ俺は未だに会
がずっとだと思うけど一番人でもいいが
表記されたらちょっとうれしいなぁとか
思ったりしてます
youtube さんって話ですよね話す
よ僕の個人的な悩みというかああいう主に
なっているんですよ1000万にこれで彼
らのチャンネル登録者数が表記と知らない
方もいると思うんですけど実は10万人で
泊まってなくて初めてつをしっかり地道に
伸びてはいますのでもうすぐ1020万人
目指して今も頑張っておりますや本当に何
か改めて気が引き締まったというかまた
頑張ろうと思いました後やモードボタンた
と言ったのでちょっとね3月は結構動画
頑張ったんですけれども4月5月はりと音
流チュール以外の仕事がいろいろあって
いるとか結構バタバタしててあんまり3月
ほど動画更新できたりないんですけども
まぁ頻度を上げるというより自分が納得
する自分がこれだって覚えような動画を
しっかり出していきたいので動画が更新
頻度はちょっとバラバラにないと思うん
ですけどもっともの3冊もよろしくお願い
致しますそしてチャンネル登録ぜひ宜しく
お願い致しますもう今保免説きたまふ今
こういう時とみて3分前に1010万人
から増えないのは何でですかってもうば
わかんない視線10万人が増えてないんだ
と思うと競っていると思ったらいいたぁー
dl
[音楽]